Rochelle welcome to the studio
congratulations on an important Victory
you're back on 50 right now how
important was for you to get the full
point in this one
um
I don't know it just makes me feel
better about myself it's like coming
into this term I kind of felt like way
out of form because like I'm missing so
many moves like literally everywhere so
like I want to like still be able to
prove that I can win some games why was
uh why were you missing moves why did
you feel like you're missing moves have
been focusing on your academics more
leading up to them yeah I would say so
let's talk about uh today's game because
you took a very aggressive stance early
on right with the Sicilian classical
Sicilian and she decided to go for the
erythrough Rouser did you prepare this
before the round um yeah I was expecting
this because like we literally had a
game um in the summer in juniors where
we put this exact same thing if you just
played something else after
um castles Bishop D7 it's all the way
here because last time she took on C6
instead of castles no no after Castle
Bishop D7 she took on C6
um Bishop takes and then she put like F3
I believe and we like I got a good
position but we ended up drawing because
I was playing like
really bad
so you weren't afraid of repeating the
same lines no because like
um
I mean I didn't really look at it like
much after that game but I was like I'm
sure I can play some better moves the
last time
and she actually uh deviated early on
with this movie F4
you were I would assume aware of this
line because you played quite quickly
even at this point yeah we both did
excuse me let's get back
here Bishop takes F6 Queen to B6
and I think at this point she took her
first thing after Knight to E5
a small thing Queen to E2
Rook to C8 how did you assess the
position at this point I actually really
liked my position like well actually I
didn't I didn't know because like I was
looking from my perspective and then
um I decided to get up from the board
like walk around and stuff and like on
the
um like there's this broadcasting where
it shows all of the boards so I could
look at it from her perspective and I
was like I would not like to be white
here
you can also go behind your opponent
yeah I feel creepy doing that yeah yeah
I feel creeped out whenever my opponent
does that as well so I can definitely
understand now what was the plan that
you were trying to achieve at this point
oh I was just trying to like go forward
you know go A5 double up on the C file
maybe maybe yes maybe five
um I wanted to go like
um before she played 92 I wanted to play
Knight C4 so like obviously she
prevented it so for example yeah or
something like okay
um yeah and I was gonna go like A5 A4 I
was like maybe I should bring my Bishop
to like d8 and B6
um
and I was like I couldn't see a clear
plan for white so I thought that I was
chilling here for sure definitely you
were and she did not allow you to get an
I2 C4 but you still went for uh A5 C4 B4
you're trying to make a dent in White's
position or at least grab more space
where do you feel like you took over
this game and got a decisive advantage
well I definitely knew I was better here
I didn't know how much better but I was
like wow my my friends and Coach is
gonna be so mad if I don't win this
because I was like I'm just gonna it's
just barely slightly better yeah but
like
I feel like I have the bishop here I
have like my pawns Advanced I feel like
she can't do anything besides maybe like
Knight H5
um and like I was like even if we trade
Queens which I didn't really want to do
because like I'm trying to Checkmate her
I was like even if we trade Queens I'm
probably still better there
so I was so you were confident yeah at
this point well I wouldn't say I was
confident because like I was watching my
time go lower and I was like not again
but hers was uh also yeah lower as well
but it's funny because like my last few
games I did not know how to play with
the bishop here like I was just playing
the most random moves I was like why
can't I ever make progress when I have
the Bishops because like my first game I
feel like I should have like I was doing
better and then like I just didn't know
what to do so I was just trying to
redeem myself and that you did uh let's
keep it going and I think it was some
around this point where it felt like
you're breaking through finally putting
a lot of pressure on the C file I wasn't
sure how good it was like to like
play D5 and stuff when we both had so
little time but I was like oh it was I'm
gonna go for it because I don't like
nothing to lose at this point absolutely
and I mean you got handsomely rewarded
for it very nice win Rochelle
congratulations uh what are you going to
do during the rest day are you going to
spend it with your friends looking at
chess what's the plan
um
I'll probably do like a bunch of
homework because I'm not gonna lie I've
been procrastinating that like a lot
um
and you're a senior in high school I'm a
junior junior got it I'll just out of C
I don't know
well we'll uh definitely let you go rest
let you go do your homework and we'll
see you in a couple of days
Rochelle I just want to remind you that
we had a conversation during the U.S
junior girls championships where you and
Jennifer proudly announced that you were
prepared to replace us and it will do a
much better job in the commentary booth
and I said welcome welcome welcome
that's what I wanted to hear
very good Rochelle enjoy your free day
thank you
uh we have a result yes